what we're gonna do is make sure that we
take advantage of this whole idea that
Exponential's indices right and
logarithms have this kind of inverse
special relationship right one undoes
the other we're looking at the same kind
of situation namely proportional growth
and we're just looking at from two
opposite perspectives so every index law
that you're pretty familiar with like
back from you seven eight okay every
next law has its equivalent log law
which some of which we've actually been
using a little bit but we want to make
sure they're firm in our heads okay so
on the left hand side what I'm going to
do is have all of these index laws
there's I've got one two three four five
of them and then we're going to have an
equivalence log law that goes with it so
these will be the log laws I'm
drastically rouen around in a space but
we'll see how we go okay
start real real basic ok so the first
one I have to think about is what we
call the zero index when you take any
number I'm just saying a is any number
and you raise it to the power of zero
what's the answer it's always 1 right
very good now this is a basic index law
and it's got an equivalent log law how
would we rewrite this equation not as an
exponential equation but as a log
equation if I write log base the base of
this will become the base of this so
it's still base a very good but here are
my numbers sort of rearrange a little
bit what's my argument going to be it's
gonna be 1
very good and therefore what I get is
the last number is a 0 right so you can
have any base if you're taking log of
any base of 1 your answer is 0 so this
is just look at the same thing but from
the opposite direction stay simple a to
the power of 1 it's the identity index
so when you raise anything to the power
of 1 you get just the base that you got
back right ok let's think what's the
equivalent log law that goes along with
this I can just rewrite the same
equation log base a of a equals 1 very
good so you're like okay base is a if
the arguments the same number you're
getting again they're sort of one and
this comes from over here these were
simple now let's just amp it up a little
bit okay
one of the first things you learn with
your index laws is when you multiply
numbers that have the same base right so
we would generally write it like so if
you've got the same base on both sides
they're both twos are the both threes on
they're both eight hundreds and they've
got different powers what do you do to
those powers a to the power of M + n so
when we're multiplying these we add the
indices now when it starts to get tricky
right what does the log equivalent of
this look like well everything is kind
of reversed the positions of everything
have swapped around okay so remember how
you said here multiplying Exponential's
means adding those indices right set it
again multiplying Exponential's means
you add the indices here it is exactly
backwards so when you add logs let's
take two logs like say log base a of M
and if you add that to log base a of a
different number so again it's the same
idea of the base being identical but
over here multiplication turned into
addition this addition what do you think
that turns into multiplication is
everything reversed right so the base
stays the same but in here the argument
is going to be you told me
multiplication right so it'll be M times
n MN right m m okay we could do this in
Reverse right so if you didn't multiply
if you say what's the opposite of
multiplication division right very good
what we do with these indices what
happens same thing but it splits
negative right so instead of adding them
my indices are gonna be subtract it
right yeah i minus them yeah okay yeah
come over to log land over here log base
a of some number and here see how
division turned into subtraction well
here subtraction is going to turn into
division right the ghost of a block
returns okay so who you can see here
here's my subtraction and then what it
turns into is and divided by n M divided
by N
okay so there's this division okay now
this has some important implications for
example let's think about doing
something like this let's just go back
to this multiplication one we saw it's
got this application this is what
happens when you do the opposite what
happens when you do this but repeatedly
so if I had a to the power of M and I
multiplied it by a to the power of M and
did it a whole bunch of times right so
in other words I'm raising a power to
another power okay like so what happens
to this yeah my indices are going to
multiply here now think about why this
is okay maybe you wanna shut this down
in another color underneath let's just
think about some examples of this right
if I had a to the power of M and I was
squaring that what's that an
abbreviation for its ADA power of M
times itself do great that's what
squaring is right so this would be the
long form which is rather inefficient
it's why we don't write it like that
that'll be the long form right but come
back to this rule up here what happens
when you multiply these two numbers yeah
it's gonna be M plus M that's a to power
of two M so you can see where that
multiplication comes from yeah you
probably don't need me to rehearse but
if I did this to the power of three how
would it be different at a power of M
times a to the power of M times head a
power of M and you're gonna add all
those indices right M plus n plus M you
get three n so do you see why that works
okay come over here you have to think
for a second right what's the equivalent
of this guy in logs hmm
this one is taking a the power of M and
multiplying repeatedly however many
times you want n times so here remember
how multiplication turned into addition
so what do you think I should do here
I'm not going to repeat multiplication
over and over again what am I going to
repeat I'm gonna repeat addition right
so I'm gonna add log a + log base a of M
I'm gonna do this and add it to itself
over and over again if I add it to
itself n times then I'll have a lots of
them do you agree with that so that
makes this so I'm repeating addition
here yeah what does that become when you
add logs together what did this tell me
you're multiplying right so here how
many times are you multiplying M by
itself that many times how many times
you added it right so that's why this is
what we call the power rule right you
taught me to multiply M by itself and
number of times so that's why this n
kind of sneaks up the top here basically
it's just a special version of this guy
but instead of two different numbers
I've just got the same number over and
over again repeatedly okay now where
this thing goes is actually there's not
a separate index law for this but it's
an application of this this change of
base law right which we've used here you
need to know where it comes from and you
must be able to explain it the short
answer is it comes from here first let's
just state it if you've got some log
right and you're like I don't like the
base being a is like a weird number it's
really hard to work with right I can
change this space using a fraction right
so I just have some other logs and you
can really choose any base that you like
so I'm just going to call this X it
could be base 10 which is on your
calculator could be base 8 which is also
on your calculator and then what goes
here in the arguments for each one yeah
well be on top and a on the bottom
precisely it's easy to remember because
this bottom number goes to the bottom
and then this top number goes through
the top okay
now this is good I can know it but you
have to be able to prove it so I'm going
to show you how once I find where my
eraser is okay underneath this you've
got this list here
maybe you wanna make a little subheading
for yourself which is proving change of
base law proving change of base law I'll
do it over here so you guys can have
that space